[Music]
you think it's gonna work there's only
one way to find out
well you better find out fast my sensors
indicate he just arrived all right i'm
going in
before you do
if i could give you one piece of advice
yeah
don't go easy on him
hey thanks for coming in have a seat
right there to be honest i'm a little
surprised you agreed to this this is
against all legal advice that i've gone
the last thing i posted was a script uh
it was actually made for me by lawyers
i've been having to bite my tongue for
this whole month while we collect all
the evidence and that's that's what's
messed me up the most man not being able
to come out and just talk well we
appreciate you coming in and finally
talking but you know okay we've already
done the investigation we already have
all the evidence that's what these boxes
are here for so we know what you did you
know you're this crypto mastermind
you've got multiple wallets hundreds of
tokens we've got them all okay i am no
crypto mastermind all right i'm
literally a content creator and i
trusted the wrong people and it's led to
this disaster that i'm in and i really
want to apologize about being led by
somebody that i should not have trusted
so much i should have invested more of
my time into really understanding what
went on instead of relying on others and
for this i hold my hands up that's
absolute bull you can't just scapegoat
sam pepper you know i mean don't get me
wrong he's a bad dude but let's be
honest you're looking pretty bad here
too buddy you were the ambassador of a
kid's charity coin and sold within 24
hours it was the actions of one
individual that caused the entire
project to not be able to sustain itself
which was the original plan not this
again okay we're going in circles buddy
look let's take a quick break i'm gonna
go grab a cup of coffee don't you go
anywhere okay i'll be right back
he's not confessing even after
everything he just keeps saying it's sam
what do i do well i ran a few
simulations and i really think you
should try something else you know i
don't believe in treating the witnesses
hostile no not that so far you've been
leading the conversation try having him
start from the beginning and see if you
can catch him in a lie it'll make it
harder for him to backtrack all right
okay we're gonna try something different
i'm gonna actually try to give you a
chance here do you have any actual
evidence for what you're saying here
everything i'm about to say has been
investigated and looked at by numerous
blockchain detectives oh blockchain
detectives huh yeah my partner told me
you sent in some evidence of you
confronting sam pepper or something yeah
we'll we'll play it right here on the
screen
we can see his wallets where he's
literally got hundreds of thousands of
dollars he must be hiding something to
lie to me about this and then show me
your wallets but right now all the proof
i have is that you made a ton of money
sam
bro sam then help help me help you then
all right help me help you but right now
it looks like you made a ton of money
bro and you've lied to me and said you
didn't and that's what's hurting me the
most what hurts me the most is that you
lied bro i'm telling you i didn't make a
[ __ ]
all right i'm gonna pause it right there
um i'm gonna be honest with you kay
there's a there's a problem with the
evidence you're showing here that wallet
you're showing on screen right now that
has all this money that sam pepper
supposedly made it doesn't belong to sam
pepper i personally traced it down it
belongs to somebody named boinkboink i
actually called boinkboink to confirm
this okay uh is is this boinkboink.eth
yeah that's me
hey you're not sam pepper are you
nope
you have nothing to do with sam pepper
nope ck not only were you wrong about
sam pepper owning this wallet you put on
screen instead had 170 thousand dollars
all the proof i have is that you made a
ton of money sam you also slandered
someone else's reputation
in this ridiculous quest to be
completely innocent i mean what do you
have to say for yourself man everything
i'm about to say has been investigated
and looked at by numerous blockchain
detectives kay you've already said that
and look i hate to ask this but are
these blockchain detectives in the room
with us right now okay the blockchain
detectives that i hired over the past
few weeks have found reasonable evidence
that suggests that many of these wallets
connect back to sam himself wait wait
wait wait slow down now okay you're
changing the subject on me we can go
there but uh to be clear now you're
talking about the pre-sale list sam had
you're saying those wallets are secretly
his what evidence do you have for that
and the biggest concern and what we've
really found out and what led us down a
deeper rabbit hole was that if you type
in all of these twitter names on the
left half of them are fake not even real
accounts who even knows if these
accounts ever existed so the people that
sam are trying to verify are real people
putting money into the pre-sale are in
fact fake people that don't exist
currently it's looking extremely likely
that these wallets are owned by one
single person so that means that one
individual owned
12.24 of the total supply which is
obviously insane okay let me just stop
you there bud not only do these people
exist but you were wrong about the most
basic piece of information a lot of
those names aren't twitter handles at
all they're telegram handles
like this pronous 333 the example you
gave here but
he a hundred percent exists he called
himself the wordsmith of the wild west
as we can see from an archive or take
another guy from this pre-sale list
which is all controlled by pepper he
simply went by jamie when i reached out
and interviewed him but one of the
things k said is that you guys in the
pre-sale list didn't exist and that you
guys secretly were controlled by
sam peppers like sam pepper y'all were
fake accounts and sam pepper controlled
everything
but that's not true is it
no no no not at all a lot of us actually
lost a lot of money on save the kids
like me personally i lost 6b as well so
kate your whole theory about sam pepper
secretly controlling 12 of the coins and
all these accounts being fake it's just
more incorrect information i mean for
all this so-called self-investigation
you've done you've uncovered nothing but
a bunch of false information which you
used to paint yourself as innocent and
sam pepper as this evil villain but does
it ever occur to you that maybe you're
in the wrong here look just try saying
sorry to the people you affected i am
genuinely so sorry that any of this ever
happened it was never my intention and
if i could take it back i would
instantly in a heartbeat good good
actually hey that's a start you know
just leave it there don't make any more
excuses even though i was tricked by
somebody that took advantage of me and
my fan base all right look that's it
this is over
if you're gonna lie you're gonna deflect
blame okay let's see where that gets you
right look you just hang tight someone
will come get you but for now this
interview's over
that's it we're wrapping up here i may
be wrong here but i detect frustration
in your tone
you know what
a little bit
i just thought after collecting this
much evidence catching kay in this many
lies i thought he would come clean why
woody with a fan base of literal
children i assess he has a 68.2 chance
of escaping this at its current course
and that's calculating if law
enforcement doesn't intervene so what do
i do i feel like i've shown people
everything well confessions are nice but
the next best thing is an airtight case
you've demonstrated several flaws in
case defense but perhaps there's more
evidence to be found will facts even
matter at this point i'm tired of this i
know
but your work is far from over
you've got to finish what you started
as i went back to the studio i dreaded
the long night ahead but somewhere late
at night buried in the blockchain i
found something that made it all worth
it
okay you got it
ladies and gentlemen with the with the
sun pouring in through the windows here
i've been up all night researching the
so-called response of fraser k and i'm
ready to debunk it so far i've already
demonstrated that kaye's so-called
blockchain detectives are about as
reliable as dream's harvard
astrophysicist and that the conspiracy
theory of sam pepper controlling the
pre-sale list is false but i want to say
here i'm not defending sam pepper by any
means sam pepper was a key player in
save the kids the scam but so was fraser
k and with his ridiculous
self-investigation where he found
himself innocent k muddied the water by
throwing a bunch of accusations against
sam many of which are not true so i had
to clear those up but now let's move to
fraser k himself if you watched my last
video on save the kids all our reporting
ends up standing up pretty strong k
started the coin sam pepper changed the
anti-whale code and both of them have an
incredibly shady and long history in
cryptocurrency but kaye is now denying a
lot of this accountability in a new
response video that he put out he's been
basically saying he doesn't understand
how crypto works he said it multiple
times i am no crypto mastermind all
right i'm literally a content creator
and i have no technical background or
knowledge this is easily debunkable not
only because kay then reveals four
wallets of his but we also know that in
these wallets are hundreds of different
types of cryptocurrencies take for
instance his main wallet which has over
a hundred unique types and i'm just
gonna say this right now if someone owns
a hundred of anything you're not gonna
believe them when they say they have no
knowledge of that thing kate knew what
he was doing and pretending to be a dumb
influencer isn't gonna work now another
thing i want to address is kay
pretending that he was somehow a victim
of sam pepper he makes a lot of noise
about the supposed money he lost on save
the kids which he tallies up to be
thirty seven thousand dollars but i'm
going to exactly break down to you how i
lost thirty seven thousand dollars on
save the kids now as i said it doesn't
really matter if he lost money on this
scam the problem is you dumped the coin
and that you made six figures on other
cryptocurrencies but even this 37
thousand dollars he lost i'm not sure he
actually did see one of the biggest
costs he mentions is a 55 000 listing on
an app called poo coin two hours after
save the kids was launched i sent 55 000
of my own money and this was for one
single purpose if you're familiar with
crypto this website is a place where you
go to check out all of the the tokens
the graphs everything like that and that
is exactly what the 55 thousand dollars
was for now this is crazy this sounds
like a lot of money but what k doesn't
tell you is that technically he could
take back that money anytime to
understand why let me explain how this
works save the kids got on something
called the vetted list for poo coin now
to do that you have to be a top 10
contributor to their liquidity pool once
you are you will show up on a top 10
vetted list but here's the thing about
this list you can take your money back
out of these polls at any time something
that i confirmed with the poocoin
promotional team and they said that they
decided to block save the kids from the
list after everything went down
quote when tokens are blocked they can
then withdraw their poo coin lp at any
time which they should do because
there's no longer any benefit in keeping
it there so right there ladies and
gentlemen in black and white this
payment that frazier made can be taken
back out and speaking of that block sure
enough i noticed that the number six
spot
is blocked right now on poo coin so i
asked the team is that save the kids
they responded yes number six is a
blocked entry for save the kids now
what's great about this is we can still
see how much money is still in there
forty one thousand one hundred ninety
five dollars and 84 cents i asked the
listing company how much money could be
withdrawn from here after fees he starts
by saying if the 42k is withdrawn it
will turn into 21k and bmb and 21k in
poo coin and then after some calculation
he says so in total they will get back
thirty seven thousand two hundred and
twenty eight dollars which
coincidentally is about the amount he
said that he lost how i lost thirty
seven thousand dollars on save the kids
but there's actually more here i
discovered as well because after kay
confessed which wallets he owned i went
back and checked and this wallet right
here it was the largest owner of save
the kids tokens at launch let me repeat
that the person with the largest single
save the kids token balance at launch
was none other than fraser k and of
course we know what he did with these
tokens he sold so just imagine for a
second you're an ambassador of a coin
you created it you have the largest
balance and then you sell almost
immediately and then when you get caught
you blame it on sam pepper a guy who
worked for you and you say oh no i
didn't know anything about crypto but it
gets even worse than that this ladies
and gentlemen might be the point where
kaye's whole dodging of accountability
falls apart so far we've heard
repeatedly from kay about how he was
backstabbed by sam pep how sam pepper
caused everything when sam pepper sold
his tokens but given all the lies from
fraser k i wasn't sure did sam actually
sell before frasier well i went back and
checked their main wallets we know of
and what i found made me sick to my
stomach here's a little spreadsheet i
made with their main wallets along with
their first cell of save the kids in the
transaction id and for reference these
tokens were given to them at june 5th at
10 26 p.m utc time and if you take a
look at this and i put their fast to
sell in bold you'll notice that it was
not sam pepper who sold first it was
actually frasier k frasier k sold 30
minutes before sam pepper an entire 30
minutes before this man who threw this
guy under the bus completely and played
innocent in actuality started selling
first now again is sam pepper a dirtbag
yes you only have to watch my other
videos to know that i am not a fan of
sam pepper i do not like sam pepper he
had a huge role in this scam but for k
to play the victim when all the evidence
is against that narrative i can't sit
idly by and let him lie to people sam
pepper was not the first to run for the
door sam pepper just ended up selling a
little faster in the end now other
things you should also probably know is
that k is not past his days of trying to
silence people see right before
launching his new response video kay
sent another cease and desist letter not
to me this time it was to sam pepper now
i can't show you it on screen because
unfortunately it was marked confidential
but what i can tell you is that part of
the cease and desist letter was
apparently because sam pepper had given
me and some ordinary gamers my
co-investigator who you should watch
here he'd given us information that's
right ladies and gentlemen if k can't
stop me from talking he'll try to stop
sam pepper from talking and i confronted
frasier about this by the way to give
him a chance to deny it because we all
know that we take pepper with a grain of
salt but he didn't respond for comment
but it just seems like more and more
action by frasier to deal with this by
silencing people rather than coming out
and just being honest about his actual
dealings and save the kids now at this
point we've already debunked nearly
every point of fraser's
self-investigation and proven his
response to be massively wrong at best
and completely manipulative at worst but
there's another feature here i'd like to
discuss these giveaways that fraser k
addresses see he says it was there's
only one mistake in all of the giveaways
so it's come to my attention that one
giveaway out of all of them was missed
and this is a 500 giveaway to a single
person but this is not true the wallets
i'm about to show you not only won
multiple giveaway tokens from fraser k
but some of them are also getting paid b
and b
by k coincidence maybe but when five
wallets when two or more of your
giveaways and multiple of them are
getting paid from your main wallet it
starts looking pretty suspicious take
for instance that second wallet on
screen here
ox4984 it won three giveaways from k it
was also paid five thousand dollars from
kay's main wallet and then oops what's
this it also bought into the save the
kids pre-sale probably a coincidence i'm
sure but not only that this wallet which
won all these giveaways
also got paid by hilariously enough two
known sam pepper wallets in fact the
first ever transaction on this wallet is
from none other than sam pepper.eth
making it likely that this wallet which
won multiple of fraser's giveaways is
either sam pepper or someone close to
kay and sam i asked sam about this he
denied it being his wallet but tell me
again how all of these so-called
giveaways were on the up and up i mean
sure some money was definitely given
away to real people but there's some
seriously shady business too which kay
has obviously not addressed why do the
people he's picking to win also have a
history of being paid by known sam
pepper wallets and his wallet in the
past i thought they were random
strangers but now that we've talked
about these giveaways i have one last
surprise for you guys one last big
reveal so far most of these videos have
been focused on the perpetrators of the
save the kids scam but i'd like to shift
gears and talk about the victims of save
the kids the fans previously we didn't
know who invested and why but now that's
changed because i just got access to the
public pre-sale request list and why
that's important is because in order to
get on it you had to answer some
questions most notably why you wanted to
buy save the kids and how long you
planned to hold it the purpose of me
sharing this is to get you in the heads
of some of the people who bought in to
save the kids token many of whom who
lost money because right away from the
responses it's pretty clear
some of them just wanted to make money
why do you want to buy lambo lambo i
want to buy lambo lamborghini sir
lamborghini i want to buy lambo so i can
afford lambo to buy lambo to buy a lambo
but others weren't in it for the money
they were just fans support the cause
and faze clan love faze clan and what
you guys are doing faze moon heard about
this through follow frasier and my other
faves from faze first of all i like the
ambassador very much i've been following
phase k
for a long time and then interestingly
in the how long you plan to hold section
this person said i plan to hold until
phase k abandons this project just
kidding well turns out k wasn't kidding
these are just a few of the responses
there are almost a hundred responses
like this that mention phase
specifically others mention a specific
phase member like k or nikken others
really just wanted to save the kids
quote why do you want to buy because i
want to help participate for charity
help people with charity and earn some
money as well because being on a charity
coin and getting rich at the same time
is just so satisfying and what this
shows is the real humans behind a scam
like save the kids they don't all go in
for the same reasons they're not just
numbers on a chart these were real
people that this affected nobody seems
to care about that everything is about
blaming sam pepper and how k didn't do
anything wrong but the truth is it
wasn't all sam pepper's fault k owned
the biggest wallet he started selling
before sam and he created this coin
don't let him lie to you not about that
or about sam making hundreds of
thousands of dollars from save the kids
because the evidence just isn't there
these blockchain detectives that he
hired are a joke they mistook boinkboink
for sam they mistook an entire pre-sale
wallet list for a conspiracy about sam
pepper owning everything see the truth
is all these influencers love shilling
crypto when it's fun and making them
money but the second people get scammed
and people start to think there might be
some trouble involved everybody
disappears nobody knows how crypto works
and it's impossible to get anyone to
take any accountability and i can't help
but think
it's ultimately going to take law
enforcement getting involved for anyone
to actually stop this but whether that
happens tomorrow or 10 years from now
either way you can count on me being
here in the 10 million dollar studio
losing sleep tracking down these cases
for you drinking too much caffeine
because i won't stop until we do
actually save the kids
all the
[Music]
are you promises same as choice